the reason Sacro is my favorite from
software is the attention to detail on
that game it's absurd I like Sacramento
like elderly
because sakuro
had Lupu that the last Boston Seco the
only other boss I've ever there's like
three bosses in my entire life I fought
that gave me more trouble I heard me
outside it was the the last Boston
secara he gave me issues uh because he
he ridiculous like he was fast he kept
switching swords switching weapons
switching stance jumping up throwing
lightning at you and it was it was a
battle of attrition because he had so
much hell and lukewig off of bloodborne
this the first DLC boss that dude I
literally right quit I I went I went
looted it's on my channel I went crazy
fighting that dude now you know uh there
there there's a couple bosses I would
say it costs from uh bloodborne uh he's
just as hard but
lubu's